كشف الحرس والثوري الايراني بحضور رئيس
الايراني ابراهيم الرئيسي وقاده الحرس عن
صاروخ قال انه فرط صوتي اطلق عليه اسم
فتاح واعلن الحرس الثوريه ان صاروخ صنعه
خبراء مركز صناعه الجويه التابع له وذكرت
وكاله الانباء الايرانيه ان الصاروخ يتميز
بمحرك يعمل بالوقود الصلب ويصل الى سرعه
عاليه ويحلق داخل الغلاف الجوي وخارجه
ويبلغ مدى الصاروخ الفن واربعمائه كيلو
متر من جهه يقال القاله قائد القوات
الجويه والصاروخيه في الحرس الثوري العميد
امير علي حاجي زاده قال انه لا يمكن
استهدافه او تدمير هذا الصاروخ عبر انظمه
الدفاعات الجويه واضاف ان ايران باتت
واحده من اربع دول تمتلك تقنيه الصواريخ
الفرد صوتيه
مراسل الجزيره نور الدين غير نور الدين
مرحبا بك معنا اذا حدثنا عن اهميه الاعلان
واهميه هذا الصاروخ ايضا الفرد صوتي بحد
ذاته
نعم محمد هناك مستويات متعدده للحديث عن
هذا الصاروخ الذي اعلنت عنه طهران اليوم
وخاصه الحرس الثوري الايراني باعتباره
احدى اهم المؤسسات المشرفه على الصناعات
الصاروخيه هنا في ايران عندما بدانا
بالجانب التقني للصاروخ هذا الصاروخ كما
تقول طهران هو صاروخ فرض صوتي ويعني هذا
ان ايران وصلت الى هذه التقنيه باعتبار ان
هذا الصاروخ هو اول صاروخ فرض صوتي تعلن
عنه طهران ربما لديه خصوصيات متعدده تختلف
عن بقيه الترسانه الصاروخيه البالسيه التي
تمتلكها طهران هناك المسافه 1400 كلم لكن
ما يبدو خفيا لحد الساعه هو الراس الحربي
لهذا الصاروخ عاده ما دائبه ايران على
الحديث عن وزن الراس الحربي خاصه اذا ما
تحدثنا عن اخر صاروخ اعلنته طهران وهو
صاروخ خيبر وتحدث عن راس حربي يبلغ وزنه
1500 كيلوغرام الان طهران لم تتحدث عن وزن
هذا الراس الحربي لكن تحدثت عن خصوصيات
اخرى قد اكثر اهميه بالنسبه لايران واكثر
اهميه في الصناعات الصاروخيه الايرانيه
وهي ان هذا الصاروخ تبلغ سرعته 13 الى 15
ماخ اي ما يعادل 15 الف كيلو متر في
الساعه بالحديث الاعلامي هنا في ايران يتم
الحديث على ان هذا الصاروخ لديه القدره
للوصول لاسرائيل باعتبار انها تصنف ضمن
قائمه الاعداء الايرانيين قد يصل الى
اسرائيل ما بين 10 الى خمسه عشر دقيقه منذ
لحظه اطلاقه بالاضافه الى انه قادر على
المناوره في الغلاف الجوي الايراني وهذا
يعطي خصوصيه كما يتحدث الحرس الدوري
الايراني هنا خصوصيه لعدم رصدهم من قبل
انظمه الرادارات وكذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي
لكن الحديث عن اهميه هذا الصاروخ في البعد
العسكري تبدو اكثر اهميه خاصه اذا ما
اخذنا في عين الاعتبار التهديدات التي
تطاله ايران خلال هذه الايام سواء من قبل
اسرائيل او من قبل
غربيه اخرى وربما التهديد على ان هناك
خيارات متعدده على الطاوله وخاصه الخيار
العسكري هنا قد تكون الاجابه الايرانيه
بانها مستعده لهذه الخيارات وهذا ما اعلنه
اليوم الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس خلال
كشف عن هذا الصاروخ حينما تحدث على ان هذا
الصاروخ يشكل احدى اساس القدرات الردعيه
لارا بمعنى انه سيقف حائل دون القيام باي
هجوم يستهدف ايران لذلك تحدث هنا الرئيس
الايراني عن معادلتين معادله ان هذا
الصاروخ لم يعد للهجوم ولكن للردع لكن
سيتم استعماله حينما تتعرض ايران لاي هجوم
ولذا هنا القراءه العسكريه المهمه لدى
ايران لانها تستعد لكل السيناريوهات وخاصه
السيناريوهات العسكريه وقد يشكل هذا
الصاروخ نقطه اهميه في العمل العسكري
الايراني في مواجهه التهديدات والتحديات
كما قال الرئيس الايراني لكن كذلك لا يجب
هنا ان نغفل الجانب السياسي لهذا الصاروخ
لا يجب ان نفصل ما بين ما يحدث الان على
الساحه السياسيه وخاصه فيما يرتبط بالملف
النوع الايراني والمفاوضات هنا قد تكون
الرساله الايرانيه بالاعلان عن هذا
الصاروخ بان المفاوضات النوويه المفصوله
بشكل كامل عن البرنامج
ولا يمكن ان تدخل ايران لاي مفاوضات تشمل
هذا الجانب من طيران نور الدين غير شكرا
جزيلا